did isha have any feelings about you
going on the show like does she have
feelings um no she no because i mean
that was a long time ago
she was just happy for me do you want me
to meet cyber would you
let's see what let's see what she says
oh you guys are getting it all right now
this is so funny
we want to know if there's the chance
that things
would or could turn romantic
um that's a great question well let's
talk about
season three of this series it's called
twin
my heart and you are at the center of
all these i think all women right just
vying for your
love and attention are you in love i
would say that's a spoiler and you have
to tune in to find out
okay okay are you happy i'm happy yes
yeah i'll start there i'm happy what
made you want to participate
in this series i am i was looking for
a a girlfriend a companion and it's been
very difficult to
find that in la specifically so
i was just like why not why do you think
it's hard to find love
in la specifically well i guess i'm in
the entertainment space
and i just feel like i haven't met
someone
who's right for me i don't know you know
a lot of my friends are in happy
relationships
i just haven't found the right person
yeah so you know i was excited about the
show i was optimistic i was like uh
let's switch it up let's do something
different and that's what i did
overall how would you say the experience
doing this
show was oh my gosh overall it was an
amazing experience i
didn't really know what to expect i was
a little bit nervous going into it
because you know
it's a reality show and there's 10
different women
how are they all going to mesh together
how are they going to mess with me are
they going to like me are they not
um so those are all things to consider
but overall after doing a show and
everything
it was amazing i'm super happy i did it
what do you feel like you
learned about yourself doing this and
like learning about what you want
i learned how to talk to different women
i'm not gonna lie because i've
i haven't even been on that many dates
so i kind of was just
thrown in there and you know just do it
pretty much
and i really enjoyed it because it
really you know got me out of my comfort
zone
i'm not gonna lie i've not always been
the best
i i would say talking to women so
i know a lot of people when i i've told
several people that and they just don't
believe me
i have a personality but i would say
that i'm i'm not
like i'm always thinking the next thing
to say i get nervous when it comes to
talking to girls
so i just i learned how to
talk to women better basically what were
the challenges of dating with cameras on
you
and with uh feeling like you knew people
were gonna watch this
after you filmed it you know your date
is being
broadcasted to everyone and so there is
a camera on you
and so you don't know like hopefully you
know you're trying to
play the date as if there's not a bunch
of people watching but
there is and there are cameras so uh
you kind of just gotta try to not see
the cameras and just focus on the person
who's in front of you
but yeah it definitely it it's i'm sure
it was a challenge for some of the girls
too to get used to
just being a camera being being like
having a camera in front of your face
all the time in general i guess is it
hard to
date because you are someone with a lot
of followers and that people have
interest in does it make it difficult
uh yeah of course i mean that definitely
is something
you have to keep in mind and potentially
watch out for
is someone using you because i've
definitely known situations in the past
uh
not well yeah the situation i've gone
through and i know some friends that
have gone through it
that people will use you once they see
an opportunity in yourself that's what
comes with it honestly
so i'm kind of prepared for that with
every girl i talk to
i do want to ask you about a tweet that
you sent out on february 11th
oh you said this is a direct quote
quote i'm pissed off how the f
do i get so much hate for a show amazing
opportunity by the way
i did three months ago when i was single
capital letters correct um yeah
i would love to explain the tweet um
yeah i was definitely very irritated
because again this was an amazing
opportunity for me
and uh as soon as i posted about it i
got a lot of backlash
from fans that support
me and a friend of mine my name is aisha
we do videos together and there is this
ship for us on the internet and our
support like our supporters are
very supportive of us and so they
definitely got offended when i was
talking about
going on a dating show i feel like a lot
of them don't understand too also that
this was filmed
two three months ago but
besides that like i feel like like they
should be happy for me
and not coming at me and so yeah i was a
little bit irritated by that
i tweeted that a little bit out of
aggression
which i should have just paused for a
little bit and i probably wouldn't
tweeted that probably will go take that
down after this interview actually but
yeah i mean it is what it is i mean
we're just we're friends like there
shouldn't have been
like no there was no talk before me
going on the show or anything like
we were just friends she was super happy
for me and
yeah that's really all there is to it
are you still just friends
oh my god
oh my god i'm about to answer this
question a lot yes we are friends
we are not we are not together right now
we're not i literally on the internet we
don't even like
kiss we don't talk about any like
anything relationship
wise we just do videos together and
people love us together and that's kind
of how this
all started i only am asking because
you said in the tweet when i was single
oh yeah i know i i had a few friends to
also
text me when i put that out and they're
like you said was single when i was
messaging it
i didn't really think about it like that
um so yes uh yeah we're not together
did i have any feelings about you going
on the show
like does she have feelings um no
she no because i mean that was a long
time ago
yeah she had no she was just happy for
me yeah i think this is all nice to hear
i'm so glad
that we're wearing the air oh my gosh
that i should text you wouldn't that be
crazy if it actually wasn't
it would be funny i'd like me to
facetime her and have her set the record
straight
do you want me to facetime her would you
let's see what let's see what she says
oh you guys are getting it all right now
this is so funny she might be in the
hair salon so we'll see
do you want to show the camera
[Music]
hey hey so i'm going to interview right
now hi asha
sorry to put you on the spot it's
because i put him on the spot and we
just you know the fans do love you guys
together
and we want to know if there's the
chance that things
would or could turn romantic
um that would be great question um
my answer is time will tell
will tell that's not a no
what did you say uh i didn't really
answer the question
that was a question for you oh okay
well um you look good
oh thank you
okay all right thanks thanks for
joining i love that i love messing
with her and putting her on the spot
that's so funny well okay so she said
time will tell
well now what's your answer i'm i'm
actually
that's interesting that she answered
that with that answer uh time will
tell i'll be i'm giving you the same
answer
is is she someone that you could see
dating though
does she check all your boxes do you
feel like there's chemistry
i can't i can't i can't go that i can't
answer that all right like
now i feel like we're going too far with
the eyeshadow
all right i will say it is cute though
because you do smile a lot when you talk
about her
yeah i do i mean we we have we do have
great chemistry uh she's one of them
she's an amazing friend we hang out all
the time uh
and and yeah i mean she's an amazing
girl
leave it at that is there anything that
you
think fans will learn about you as they
watch your journey on this show that
might
surprise them honestly i really
the fans that know me um i was just
myself
i feel like i pretty much uh i
am who i am on social media like i don't
hide anything
and so for the the new fans and for
everyone that's watching
uh this is the first time seeing me i'm
exactly like i am in the show
in person i don't hide anything um
yeah and i just feel like that's why
i've gotten to where i am because it's
i just show my personality and it is
what it is
i mean you're a tick talker you're a
youtuber you're an
actor you sing where
where do you see yourself in i guess
five years what's the ultimate
goal i would like to be on a successful
show or or a movie
um because that is why i moved to los
angeles california
four years ago i kind of luckily social
media is a little bit of luck
and i got into that when i got to social
media when i moved out here
but yeah acting and music is my main
passion so
i would love five years that's a long
time so hopefully by then i will be
very successful in one of those two
categories
is there a dream role or a dream co-star
i would say a very successful show on
netflix um
i don't have a success i don't have a
specific role that
i would want because i love comedy i
love playing comedic roles i love
playing
dramatic roles i i i'm down to play
anything
season two
i would love that that would be amazing
i feel like
i've been talking to you now for like 15
20 minutes
you seem like you have such a good head
on your shoulders
and you seem very i guess just like even
healed about everything which i think is
a great quality
to have as you've been navigating i
guess hollywood what is your secret
to maintaining that yes i do stay out of
drama
um because that's not what i'm
interested in i do believe in myself
highly i feel like i've had a calling
from a very young age
to do what i'm doing see i have an
amazing support system
through my family i just keep pushing
honestly there's
there's been i've lived out here for
four years there's been a lot of ups and
downs
that's what's going to come with moving
to la specifically
and following the stream of
entertainment because it's i'm not going
to lie to anyone watching
it is hard but if you're passionate
about doing something then do it
um and don't have a plan b always have a
plan a and stick to your plan a
and i never thought about not making it
i always just knew
when when it's going to be that time
that i progress
and be successful in what i want to do
so absolutely